Jason Kendall been a while since I've
spoken to him he's a former all-star
catcher how many years of 15 and 15
years in the show what are you doing now
I'm actually a special assignment coach
with the Royals okay so I'm still into
it but before we get anything I have I
think I saw the real Buttermaker last
week you guys were talking earlier I was
back in the green room about the the
walk is as good as a hit
yeah Bad News Bears well let her make
her and walk yep absolutely and so I'm
watching one of my son's games and I
behind me it was your typical Little
League game where the parents are
yelling each other and nobody's even
watching the game yeah and their coach
and this is honest to god strewth their
coach says some guys we need to get
somebody on base right now get hit by a
pitch please and I look at my wife and I
go what did you hear that so getting
back to your walks better than hit this
guy actually really he was serious he
told these kids go get hit they're 12
okay okay now here you are as a former
major leaguer Duke are you coaching your
kids okay
parents are the worst that's the worst
part of Little League it's it feels like
the parents without a doubt okay how
tough is it for you as a former player
an all-star to be able to teach without
the other parents kind of saying no
maybe this is how it should be done very
very fortunate my little league team the
spikes is what we call it what we're
called I have the best parents ever I
have not had one problem with anybody I
don't know if it's because of the
tattoos that I have or not but how many
like but I think that you got sleeves I
got what I have was a long time ago but
yeah I got so I think that when I have
they think I'm looking a little bit
crazy but no I have unbelievable parents
okay but other parents they're nuts I
could tell you stories that you would be
like Bolivar are you kidding me I mean
just like the Buttermaker when he was
dead serious when he told that kid give
me give me a story without any names
about Little League yeah okay well we
come back by 11 runs left four runs in
the ninth inning and we win our 17 I
guess yeah and the other team I couldn't
tell you where their friend we're
walking out and the head coach was
cursing at these kids because he
couldn't believe and when I mean cursing
pretty good a lot it's so I had to go
over there and I said hey you know what
this is a this is unacceptable number
one cuz you got you have grandparents
you have parents siblings walking by and
and it was f-bomb and it was just it was
on so I went overnight said hey listen
you what you need to do is get here
because you're embarrassing yourself but
more importantly you're embarrassing
your kids and it's that's just one I
mean there's another so this isn't even
your just no no this is your another
team yeah and it's there was another one
where the guy for the kid forgot to tag
up from second base flyball right field
and he got thrown out and there's third
base coaches yelling at him that says
well instead of yelling why don't you
just tell them that you know when the
guy catches the ball in the air you have
to step on them and then that's called
tagging up instead of yelling at him
yeah these kids don't know but when did
we get to the point where coaching
became yelling when parents are living
vicariously through their kids but even
you know like coaches professionally
that that if I don't think if I want to
say something to my kids and I want to
get through to him I but yelling does
not get through to him but man if I say
you really disappointed me that's that's
a you know or you know just talk to them
and so if I if I yell at you I just feel
like at some point you tune me out and I
don't know where you're gonna snap yeah
what are the two yeah but it's it's not
a good look when you see and look there
are legendary coaches who have done this
but it just feels like like when you go
to argue balls and strikes and you see a
manager go toe-to-toe with an umpire
what is that for like Moore's more than
anything protecting their player what
can I say something to the umpire in a
way that doesn't have to be a show and
if you have a catcher who is actually
running the game as prepared they do the
talking for you now when you see in
diems the managers can eject now because
of obviously because of instant replay
but you know there's an occasion where
some way but when you see a manager
arguing now it's all for protecting the
play they have to which you have to
stand up for players whether you're
right or wrong
but how
you give the message to an umpire as a
catcher I have straight ahead just
straight ahead just don't even look back
at it first thing I always said when I
went out - hey Bob how the how's the
wife and kids
I've had beers in an uptight that goes a
long way because these guys have a
difficult job if you think about it but
you've had beers with umpire oh yeah I
mean like the spring training at lunch
would have taken us I mean they're good
guys for the most part um and there's
there's a couple out there but that it's
just how it is everywhere but these guys
you got a say but they go I think they
get two two-week vacations a season I I
believe I'm not sure but I mean you're
going three days you're out of a hotel
yeah you're gonna Colorado you're going
to San Diego you're going to Milwaukee I
mean this guy's got it so I had when I
had caught I developed a relationship
with him and trust me come the
seventh-inning I might get that
borderline pitch and I'm talking about
offensively that a lot of other players
donate but I mean you are in a
conversation from the first pitch to the
last best hitter you saw best hitter ice
with Barry Bonds
so when bonds comes to the plate and
you're catching what are you calling
etus lee you're looking at feet you're
you're you're looking at feet you're
looking at you're looking at anyway he
was playing he was a like us going and
playing wiffle ball with six-year-olds
that's how good he was at one point I
know you say you're looking at his feet
feet hands um and I had an advantage of
as far as calling a game now just with
Barry Bonds you just hope he gets
himself out I remember with Tony Gwynn
there's a four-seam fastball he done the
monthly and he'll he didn't know what do
with it he could do anything else with
everything else but the because he
wasn't used to game wasn't used to
getting something right on the plate
bonds you just kind of walk them but uh
yeah the good hitters they changed
everybody says they changed night by
night or day by day they change pitch by
pitch so the best hitter I say Barry
Bonds just because one of those guys
were you've heard the bat go through the
zone it was you know you're pretty good
what you can hear that best pitcher you
either caught or faced
well for a three-month period CC
Sabathia when I was in Milwaukee when he
got traded over from the Cleveland
Indians this guy was unbelievable when
he pitched on three days rest
he omit walk he was getting everything
they could out of CC and you know what
and he wanted it and and that's what I
mean this was a guy that was getting
ready to go to you he was an amazing at
the end of the year now I'm you know
he's gonna get a hundred million dollar
plus contract he went out there every
day what a unbelievable teammate
unbeliev he was larger than life I
guarantee you when I know he has gone
back to no Waukee since I guarantee he
gets a standing O this guy what he did
and that three months was unbelievable
so for a three-month period of time it
was him
what about at the plate did you ever
feel like I shouldn't even be up here
with this guy no you wouldn't allow
yourself to never and and the guys that
I had a hard time with the guys that
would just get called up I will never
forget I was in he was my last year
playing and I did look up at the
scoreboard and I looked up and Kendall
though for 24 this guy and I still took
the stake but I was over 24 and I hit a
hard ground ball up the middle hit off
the mound of the shortstop out so it was
over 25 I couldn't tell the guys name is
that how you ended your career no no it
was just one of those times me these
guys when you go up to the plate you
look at the scoreboard
that's it would you see to 30 you should
be embarrassed in my opinion I mean but
now it's everybody's hitting 230 240 oh
yeah they don't care that I don't care
now which I don't know it to me it's
it's it's analytics good for baseball or
bad for baseball I think it is is it's
the same thing that I I don't know all
the analytics I can't say good what I
used it for were counts guys ran on
counts guys I mean these guys are
creatures are had would that whether
they they note or don't it's you're
gonna swing it for a 1-1 count pitch
more than you will attend one you
probably you don't even think about it
but it just happens so I liked I looked
at counts a lot and III would be at the
ballpark at one o'clock
every day so I didn't have to have my
picture do this call a game I did it for
him and once you get that trust in a
picture boy it's fun but I was getting
all that information okay Joe Mauer
things seventy percent whatever at a 2-1
pitch you take then you use it does it
always gonna pop up
no but Joe Mauer talking about a good
hitter if he hit a 2-1 changeup two
months ago and he gets in that working
certain pitcher and he gets in that same
count a month later he's looking for
that pitch that were you you pop that
heater and that's what the best part
about catching is and if these guys just
watch the game today
you know what catcher is prepared and
what catchers not prepared because if
you get a big tall lefty up there all
right then you gotta do one sinker and
then another big tall left he's up there
he's good alright throw another thinker
they're not prepared as much as is
Molina heads above everybody else
without a doubt him Kurt Suzuki
everybody wants to know why the Bears
are doing so good
Kurt Suzuki has the the staff in the
palm of his hands that's pretty yeah
Lucroy okay I say those two and I also I
worked with them quite a bit but no one
has dropped Kurt Suzuki's name yet no on
in this staff at this young staff but
the Braves aren't going anywhere it's a
big surprise they're gonna be the played
well yeah Jason Kendall was with this
former baseball player 15 years
three-time all-star and I think your
fifth all-time hit by pitch is that
right I think so yeah do you is there
one that stands out and like it's 200
and how might Paulie how many times do
you know how many times your hit it was
250 something Paulie
he's at 254 and Jason your third
all-time and hit by pitches per season
in Major League history third all-time
do you is there one that you remember um
there's probably two that I remember one
one is Danny graves that mean ahead no
with a 95 fastball but I remember that's
a locker room they tried to he called
over and we had some more he was
apologizing the other one is Kevin Brown
Kevin Brown
when he was throwing 98 with I swear he
must have hit me I don't know two three
times it would hit in my bicep and it
would when it does that you throw hard
and that ball is moving a lot wait it
was spinning and I swallow then it would
drop those are the ones that you
remember did you try to get hit how long
did you try to get here not but this guy
report on me was pitch me inside that
was the report on me I had an inside-out
swing I did wear an output after it got
to the point to where I started getting
contusions on my bicep so the trainer's
made me wear the the pad and then how
many times did I try to get hit I just
wanted out of the way and it was more so
I can get up out of the way right here
and get smoked at the ribs and have a
broken rib or I can have a bruise on my
bicep but sky report was hardened
hardened hardened and if it's too hard
in he's gonna go to first base where's
the game going but what concerns could i
I brought this up that they you know
growing up there was movement with the
game you would move the runner over no
there's no movement it's either I'm
gonna strike you out or you're gonna try
to hit a home run and we're missing
McKidd watching I would not be
interested I'd be interested with the
jugs gun and I'd be interested in BP but
I don't know if I'd be interested in the
game itself because there's not enough
movement there that's a great question
and I guess the answer that I would have
for that and it makes me sick too
when you have a runner on second with a
1-1 tie game in the seventh inning
or whatever you see you guys hooking
balls into the left-field bridge it
makes me sick to my stomach that I
believe is that's something that your
manager or your hitting coach or
somebody the bench coach should be taken
care of instantly or if you have a
veteran presence in the locker room I
know that and I'm gonna say this in two
different parts but and I'll just give
an example Joey Gallo I saw the Astros
it's about a month ago
I don't know Joey Gallo but there was
the shift where there's only a left
fielder everybody else was on the right
side in but it wasn't like a it was a
0-0 ball game and
he hands enough rolling over to the
second baseman or who was in right field
if I'm a Joey Gallo steamie right there
I'm I'm saying you're a selfish player
to me that's a selfish player because
you have a freak and listen if you're in
the big leagues you can take a bunt and
drop it then you intertwine you these
guys are that good they are that good
yeah um you can even turn around before
the game in getting back to that if I
had a to 14 to 15 batting average yes
I'm trying to get that thing up but that
being said is I think when these guys
get drafted they're robots they are
complete robots so they don't know any
better there I don't think it's just an
ego thing I'm gonna try to beat this
[ __ ]
but somebody has to tell me what needs
to happen in my opinion is there's great
analytical's there's great old-school
guys there needs to be a middleman yeah
and they can figure it out because but
that's what I see umpire with the best
third strike call was who Tom Hallion
especially when he blows his back out
thank you he blew his back on I believe
on one call now he would give you the
double shoulder blade like he'd turned
back he was the Leslie Nielsen on the
Naked Gun oh yeah it was have you heard
my third strike off one here but you
gotta get I gotta get you know it's it's
it's one left hand is ah it's ripping
the phone book is what I like to do so I
turn yeah it's just like that I love it
Paulie you want to do yours do I don't
know you have one I always loved Ken
Kaiser where you could be busting your
butt to you know try to stretch a single
into a double and you get and then you
get tagged out like five feet and it
just always felt like he just can't guys
who were just like his his left arm
would go down like you're here so you're
so sad you're out yeah yes 41 in Dutch
Rennert the very theatrical on every
strike I don't know he kept up that
energy runner it was uh yeah because you
can't do it
all the strikes but that last one when
I'm on punching you out Oh a better
Beach
but what's embarrassing is when they do
with two strikes cuz that has happened
[Laughter]
you to twice oh yeah yeah right after
that good luck I don't know if you you
know you're gonna be an analyst do you
want to do that but coaching I'm trying
to figure out the little league coaching
why the big leagues I got that oh yeah I
got that but the little league I got to
try to figure that out first and yeah if
I could ever get one of those gigs where
you work once a week oh those are the
those are the good ones
yeah yeah they're hard to come by
baseball's ittle little it's gonna be
all right yeah I think so
would you show us some plays at the
plate during the break here absolutely
yeah
like old school like if we're coming in
yeah worst collision you ever saw at
home plate were you involved in I've
been innocent but you know what it goes
back to the Buster Posey rule I don't
know how much time we have but nobody
ever said Buster Posey was set up the
wrong way and I guarantee you if it
wasn't Buster Posey the price still be
closes at the plate now I'm all for the
safety of the players absolutely but
that's something you learn early I mean
if you got a home plate you instantly
the second there's a run around base or
whatever and there's basically offer you
put your your left foot on top of there
that's our top of home play that's going
straight down the third-base line
your knees stabilized you go look at
that Buster Posey play and I haven't
seen this in a while but I'm pretty sure
he's out in front yeah of the plate and
what if he's back afoot he's not getting
that short hop he's letting the ball
with his foot her his knee stays there
he tags and he gets out but the thing is
is that's the the plate the plate is as
a catcher it doesn't matter if there's a
guy running that's five 225 you're not
gonna win so when you do have the ball
in here my old man taught me this a long
time you when you have a chance to get
somebody you get them you take that ball
you put it right in the glove and you
pop around the jaw and I'll guarantee
you they won't do it again and they
won't trust me but Buster Posey
he catches that ball he has time I think
it was just one of those players I
believe it was a 12th or 13th inning
cousins didn't I believe it was cousins
cousins didn't try to you know hurt him
it was just he was a young kid as a
bang-bang play at the plate and a late
inning tie ballgame who ran into you
Sheffield knocked me pretty good Gary
Sheffield really pretty strong guy we
had got in a brawl the year before so he
was going after you yeah as well and
part in what I said in the I think in
the paper afterwards was either either
it was one of those first and third
moves which they're not even in there
anymore and he was one of the plays were
either running me over or just let me
tag you can get out I mean I had the
ball well he around me and hit me in the
head and I was actually in Los Angeles
something in front of my parents so we
ended up being into it but the next year
I was a ball centerfield I believe Brian
Giles it was one of those plays and he
was a side and he got me good it was the
third out I held on to the ball but I
kept saying the same three things over
and over uh he's just mad because we got
into it last year did we win the game
and gentleman Martin was the manager at
the time and he'd been in a wheelchair
for two weeks his back blew out and I
will chair so so you were out oh and I
will I went out struck out the next
at-bat and then I went to the mound
said hey what are the fundamental
science meaning first throw and uh you
know a slide step and he called out our
bench go get him out here the thing
about that then is they just I was at
home and I'll stay at home my brother
had to take me to the hospital at night
to uh that night to get checked out for
concussions you know yeah in the the
tracers and then they didn't do that and
I remember I called Gene Lamont at 3 in
the morning I said I'll tell you what
you better put me in the game that next
day because I said I playing I'm not
letting him do that and I ended up
playing I had zero know yeah well
there's no way I got two hits was off
channel Park I do remember that but no
way I should have been playing
especially after suffering a concussion
and being in the hospital 3:00 in the
morning he's Jason Kendall former
baseball all-star great to see you I
passed
you and your wife coming in and see you
again - and if you are watching you can
in the live look in will we'll see how
to play make that play around the plate
and we'll try to run over Jason can
perfect yeah that's and I get the ball
in my hand first right and if you want
to pop somebody in the jaw you can we're
back after this in the damn pack so
what's the one thing that we have to
know if we're rounding third hitting
home view around and third heading home
and it's a bang-bang play yeah and I'm
obviously a Murray and it is a bang-bang
play I don't care about the ball oh yeah
but if I get the ball in time I get the
ball in time I'd hold out of hand so now
you see the difference yeah you got a
baseball at your job what should I do
you're not gonna be equal if I do this
you're not gonna be eating out of a
straw so you're in you're intentionally
aiming for his head if I have time yeah
cuz they won't do together
what about plays like this like coming
in feet-first versus head first at first
if you're coming in head first even
today which obviously you can because
there's not I'm dropping on your hands
or your your but you're breaking
something yes I'm gonna hit you with the
higher yeah if you come in feet first
though you see first you doesn't matter
you're gonna get like this collision
wise you're gonna get if you so part of
the plate
yeah they should be fighting bottom but
do you intentionally show part of the
plate to give them to to let them know
that if they want to go they got to go a
little bit in this way and that's what
your zeros knew now like I said no you
don't have to you don't have that fear
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app